to paraphrase one of the great
philosophers of our time
some mother lovers are always trying to
ice skate uphill
[Music]
so
um with the ongoing strike and with uh
at least my current understanding I
actually have to reached out to
um sag after again to possibly get some
more clarification sort of kind of
specifically tailed to what I do we'll
see if I hear back but for what I
understand right now as the best way for
me to support uh the the ongoing strikes
because we support the unions
there's a lot I can't talk about uh that
I normally would so what does that leave
me with well
I can talk about
the uh industry's ignorance
if I was uh a little Snappy I'd call it
something actually you know what it's
usually only the first 30 seconds that
YouTube gets iffy about if you swear
within I think we're far enough in uh
industry
so the thing is I know I'm a little bit
of a mess I try and like get done up a
little bit more for videos most of the
time but the thing is like I keep
pushing back the shooting on this one
because I kept finding more stuff to
fold into this and I was going to talk a
lot more about the strike in specific
honestly I think I might have to do a
separate video talking about uh some of
the specific reasons why I believe the
unions are going to win in some of the
very specific miscalculations that the
studios and the producers have made up
to this point but uh that if I try and
fold all that in here it's going to be
too much that might be uh later in the
month but for right now
can we just talk about the fact that
Studios never freaking learn from the
past like at all
this entire train of thought that I'm
about to uh go through with you was
kicked off by the CEO of Paramount Brian
Robbins talking specifically about the
intentions of the animation Department
moving forward now while he is
specifically talking about animation
which is not struck by and large
um it is worth pointing out that his
General mentality is something
reflective of a lot of what's gone on in
the industry at large so it kind of just
works as a specific instance of a bigger
problem and basically what he came out
and said was you know what uh we're done
trying to make original stuff we're just
gonna deal in franchises now which is
kind of what they are already doing and
he was basically just saying yeah this
is the way it's going to be with the
planned animation stuff from that studio
you know being already established
things they're just going to milk these
properties to death that's just what
they're going to do see this is what's
really frustrating about these CEOs
and these executives
they actually don't do what movie
Executives used to do
because
this is not me necessarily wanting to
aggrandize the Past because movie
producers and Executives have uh always
been kind of messed up for various
reasons or some reasons that remain true
being anti-union being a big one of them
but there is
um a very specific thing that the
executives at a movie studio used to do
used to accept as part of their job that
just
isn't there anymore
they used to try and Scout Talent now
granted a lot of this comes from back in
the day where IPS and franchises weren't
really a thing very much
I mean these days something is
considered a false start if all you get
is uh two movies and a spin-off before
it Fizzles out back in the day sequels
used to be pretty rare like
at all and the rule of thumb for a long
time was a sequel always made less money
than the movie before but everyone was
also budgeted for less money than the
one before because that was the standard
knowledge but because they knew they
couldn't count on franchises and IPS to
just milk into Oblivion it's diminishing
returns eventually that was the accepted
wisdom they had to look for cultivate
and then decide to put their back in
behind new creators new ideas new
properties they had to be talent scouts
in addition to managing the money
in the age of the franchise and the IP
holding they don't have to do that
anymore
and it's actually I'll try not to go too
far down this path it's kind of ironic
to me that the executives part of what
is causing the strike is the desire of
Studios to make more use of AI for
artistic purposes writing performing you
know uh even effects work in some ways
but what's causing strike right now is
related to actors and writers but the
thing is
in terms of what AI which isn't real AI
it's machine learning uh what AI is
capable of right now
it actually would be much more
appropriate to replace the executives
because their decisions are based on
numbers
they look at the numbers they look at
the fact that these actors bring in more
money and these directors bring in more
money and establish properties bring in
More Money More Than a brand new thing
uh even if it is not a particularly
current or hot property if it is
establishing people already know it will
probably make more money and by
statistics yeah
that's true
but when you go by nothing but the
numbers you plug the numbers of what
makes more money
new property or established IP what
makes more money new upcoming Star or
established known name as your top
billing what makes more money
voice actors in an animated film or
celebrities if you're just going by what
makes more money more often than not
than what you end up with is the same
people starring in the same established
properties that just won't be allowed to
die nothing new no one knew no new faces
no new ideas which is effectively what's
already happening the decisions that
executives are making
already mirror the kind of choices that
an AI would make if provided the same
information that they get so it is kind
of
Darkly funny to me that they're all on
board with AI when honestly uh they are
the most replaceable
in terms of the decisions that they make
and what data they use to make those
decisions they are at the current state
of machine learning they are way more
replaceable than artists are
and that's not to say artists shouldn't
Safeguard themselves they should machine
learning will get better and until we
have proper guidelines and guard rails
to stop it from Just plagiarizing
freaking everything and getting to then
slap a copyright on it yeah no uh that
they they should be fighting for this
but anyways
the very notion of we stick to the big
established IPS We're Not Gonna bother
to cultivate new stuff and actually uh
Brian Robbins from Paramount went in
even a little further on that idea he
noted that we're not going to release an
expensive original animated movie and
just pray people will come he went on to
say covid and inflation took a hundred
million dollar movies and made them cost
200 million dollars that's rich coming
from him in specific given that one of
the Paramount movies to recently be
released uh which is also animated I'm
not going to name it in this case
because this sounds a little too much
like an endorsement but like
70 million dollar budget that's your
movie what do you mean everything costs
200 million dollars now your studio just
released a movie that cost 70 and is
probably going to make it back
but again that's the algorithm thinking
if you crunch the numbers the movies
that made the most also cost a lot now
does that mean if you spend more you
always make more no
but it the movies that made the most
cost the most by and large that's just
been the math
of course
that's just going by the Numbers there's
the fact that the more a movie costs if
a studio is not trying to just write it
off they're going to spend a hell of a
lot more on the marketing of it because
they need to make the money back so they
also push it a hell of a lot harder but
again these people have no pattern
recognition
because for an executive to say
something like that
for an executive to go look
we're just sticking with the stuff
people already know and to not even
think for a second that people are gonna
get sick of it like even some of the
very out of touch CEOs are realizing
that at least to a little bit like Bob
Iger not a man I am prone to
complimenting at the very least still
acknowledge that Marvel kind of
oversaturated the market recently they
need to be a little more selective and
put out a little bit less stuff but
they're not suddenly going to stop
making Marvel movies
and we look at something like Pixar
which used to be the bread and butter
was original films so Pixar's kind of in
a weird place they've been trying to get
back to the theaters after having a
number of films kind of go direct to
Disney plus and that kind of I think
potentially devalued the idea of the
theater going experience for Pixar for
some people maybe a little bit it's hard
to say but that might be a factor but
also you know
they've had to crank out a lot of
sequels and we look at the most recent
release from Pixar which is actually
going to turn a profit but it took a lot
longer than they expected like that film
ended up having surprising legs it
lasted a lot longer in the theater
theater then people really expected it
to but it's getting there
but that's not enough not for how much
these things cost even though Pixar
budgeting wise its budgets are a little
bit inflated slightly for an odd reason
again a little bit of a tangent Pixar
actually factors its CEO and executive
level salaries into the movie budgets
which is an interesting thing that they
can do that most Studios wouldn't and it
wouldn't make sense because for Pixar
making these movies and the shorts is
literally the only thing they do so
taking on board the cost of the
executive class as just a factor of the
budget actually kind of makes sense
because the movies is all they make
whereas someone like
David's ass love on over at Warner
Brothers Discovery it wouldn't make
sense to integrate his very bloated
salary into the budgets of Any Given
movie because he's not just managing
movies he's managing TV networks and
streaming and video games and a um a
publication arm so you know it doesn't
make sense to do it that way but that is
one of the ways that Pixar movies
actually their budgets are oddly
inflated because of the way they
calculate anyways coming back to it
since I already brought up Warner
Brothers Discovery this is the one big
thing that I just I don't get
how these Executives do not remember
this
because I remember this and I will never
stop bringing this up almost 10 years
ago now I think if I'm doing the math in
my head right
when Warner Brothers said we are in the
Blockbuster business and the only things
we intend to make are DC Superheroes
Harry Potter and Lego
do you remember how that worked out for
them
they're having to completely reboot and
retool their entire DC plan because
while there were some successes and some
hits in there at least as far as the
financials go people have their
arguments over whether it artistically
succeeded I'm not touching that right
now it didn't do what it was supposed to
do
Harry Potter diminishing turn returns at
the box office movie over movie over
movie and now they have basically no
ideas left except to just do the books
again but this time on TV Lego they let
the rights to that lapse they don't even
have the rights to that IP in that
franchise anymore
this is what happens when you put all
your eggs in one basket
if you are not working somewhere in this
monstrous Mammoth machine
that you have created on something new
eventually people get sick of this stuff
sticking to the same stuff the same IPS
and just milking it more and more
because again this factors into the
overall issue with
unbridled capitalism as we have it is
the myth of infinite growth
because to remind you it's not enough
for these corporations to make a profit
for them to make more money than they
spend they're expected to make a higher
profit than they made last year and they
are expected to do that every year
forever
that's partly why there's so many
mergers because if you can't make more
money this year than you did last year
you know it's a good way to pad your
um
your income
just be able to claim the income of
another company that you just merged
with
now suddenly it's all up it's all higher
and yeah that is literally the reason
why sometimes
I worked not an entertainment company
but at a company that acquired other
companies semi-regularly
and that is part of the reason
but in the Panic to continue to generate
income more income more Revenue more
growth forever
which of course is unsustainable I'll
come back to that in order to do that
you just Hammer harder
on the thing that on paper has gotten
you the most money
so if you're Disney you Hammer harder on
Marvel you Hammer harder on Star Wars if
you're Warner Brothers you continue to
hammer on DC because even though that's
some of your biggest flops it also had
some of your bigger successes so you
don't let it go you keep going you
Hammer the same stuff over and over and
over and over again and if you are
running out of your own stuff find
something that is an established IP and
make that your next big budget make the
Super Mario Brothers movie don't bother
finding new things
because new
is risky
and even though it is a perfectly viable
business strategy to nurture new IP at a
lower budget to lower the risk they
don't want lower returns which is what
you'll also probably get from that they
want big returns massive returns they
want to be able to go to their investors
and say we are spending this much on
this property that people already know
we expect to make this much from it
and
their investors aren't going to believe
them
if they try and pull that with something
brand new that they can't put numbers
behind that they can't prove is already
popular
and as I already said and as you
probably realize yourself this is all
unsustainable
audiences burn out they get tired of the
same thing even as audiences will tell
you they want more of the same thing the
thing is you can't actually ask
audiences what do you want because
they're going to tell you they want more
of what they already have
the best way to truly cast them off
guard and do something special is to
give them something they didn't know
they wanted but because they don't know
what that is they can't tell you
but it's unsustainable audiences burn
out
diminishing returns catch up with you
you can't grow infinitely forever
the thing is they know that
they know this is unsustainable
it doesn't matter
a sustainable business model isn't the
point when we are dealing with this
level of unfettered and unrestricted
capitalism
the point is to make as much as you
possibly can and to promise that you
will make more next year and then to do
whatever it takes to be able to do that
and if you don't if you make less you
better promise even more growth than you
promised the year that you didn't make
any they know it's unsustainable but
it's what lines their pockets
the executives
don't actually have an incentive to
create a sustainable business model
because their big payout
is based off growth and their bonuses
are based off growth and if several
years later ideally after they've left
the company with a golden parachute
if several years later
the company tanks because they funneled
all the efforts into the stuff that was
never going to last and the bubble burst
or the expense caught up with them which
is effectively what has been happening
to Netflix over the last few years
because Netflix worked on a business
model of spending more than that Netflix
was never actually profitable as a
business model but it was successful
because they kept saying we'll get
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
they kept pulling in more investors but
then they hit the ceiling on how big
they were probably going to get and
suddenly everyone went wait a minute how
are you actually gonna make all this
money back when are you going to become
profitable
and that's when they had their huge drop
in subscribers but the thing is the
executive class
if down the line their idea tanks even
if they are still the CEO
they don't have to give back all the
money and the bonuses that were built on
a Model that would eventually tank the
company
they get to keep it
no matter what happens they win
but this is also part of why and I said
I wouldn't go off too much on the unions
but I'm going to go off on it a little
bit this is part of why
they really do not want to give in to
the unions right now
because
it has been pointed out
repeatedly
that these Studios absolutely have the
money to give the guarantees of minimum
payment and of residuals that both
actors and writers are asking for we
know they have that money
because they're paying it to their CEOs
the cost of giving the actors and
writers what they want is around 20
million dollars per studio and these
CEOs most of them are making
significantly more than that even before
you factor in
bonuses and stock options
but they won't take the hit
they refuse to consider making less
money and that's why they want AI to
replace writers that's why they want AI
to replace actors not because there's
nowhere else to cut money
it's because they will not accept the
possibility of it ever
being taken from them
and that's where you get people like Bob
Iger saying very foolishly
that the writers and actors were being
unreasonable in their demands for a
livable wage in some of the most
expensive to live in cities such as Los
Angeles and New York
his salary and salaries of people like
him is largely dependent on keeping
costs low
the thing is though that's never done in
a vacuum they don't keep costs low and
then oh look we're able to just do more
or you know we're just operating at
lower cost we've increased profit no no
that always funnels up
they save money
by cutting people writing off entire
projects for taxes like David zaslov has
done
and then they get a bonus
they funnel it up to themselves and they
let actors and writers starve and lose
their homes the reason these Studios
don't learn is because they are run by
people with no Financial incentive to
learn
because as I said
the sort of stuff that uh Robin said
over at Paramount about we're only
sticking to established IPS it's been
done and it failed over at Warner
Brothers
but Warner Brothers is basically kind of
doing the same thing again already
you can make an argument for some of the
more recent stuff like oh well this is
kind of new like yeah it's all still
established IP even if it's new as a
live-action film in some of the cases of
their more successful stuff that has
come out recently
they're still doing the same thing of
course David's ass love wasn't CEO back
when this happened before so he gets to
treat it like it's a new idea
why would they ever learn why would they
ever recognize the pattern that will
eventually cause lower returns why would
they
when they can milk it for good returns
now
and get their bonuses and get their tens
of millions of dollars and refuse to let
that be paid to the actual workers and
they will get to keep it no matter what
and if they get pushed out they will get
a massive severance package on top of
that
why would they learn why would they run
the business more intelligently
we are coming borderline close to
getting into a producer's situation
where you actually make more money with
a flop than a hit we might already be
there with zazlov that's the level it's
going at and it's driven by incentives
if these people at the top get massive
payouts no matter what they do
then why would they care if what they do
is sustainable so long as it lines their
pockets now
these people don't cultivate art
they are business people
and this is not even a new problem you
can go back to Michael Eisner and his
rather Infamous quote back over at
Disney effectively saying it is not our
job to create great art it is our job to
make money
at the very least he did still add
sometimes in the pursuit of making money
we will make great art but that's not
why we're here
and that wasn't great when he said it
but even that capitulation
we will make great art in the process of
making money that that feels like it's
gone
there's no attempt to make art
just product
just content
consume
pay
here's more
buy it
I don't know how this video is going to
go down for people I am in a mood where
I am even more cynical and a little bit
more bitter towards
towards CEOs and billionaires and Folks
at the top and capitalism in general
then I usually am and on a good day I
ain't charitable
but these Studios don't learn
but they're also going to lose the union
fight and you know what
I feel like I can safely say that'll be
next week's video
as to some of the reasons why I believe
that and some of the massive missteps
and miscalculations that the studios and
Executives have made
so tune in next week for that
in the meantime what did you think about
this
thing that I have made
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon
pays my bills and keeps me accountable
so that I can't just run what I do into
the ground because you folks help me pay
my bills
and it is immensely helpful
and I appreciate it and I care what you
think
but um don't worry too much about that
what I really want you to do is I want
you to remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
foreign
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
look fulla Tara the thing that goes Oink
in the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen Auntie
Kate 808 Becky Sparks and Abby likes the
poodle Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry
Casper Adam RDO Taylor Dave Hall and
Rosalind Bell you'll see a bunch of
other names down there as well there's
plenty of things to get on the patreon
and yeah you can hear me attempt to say
your name without embarrassing myself
check out the rewards and thank you for
everyone who supports this
[Music]
thank you